في اوكرانيا سقطت مدن في قبضه روسيا ولجت
اخرى من تلك القبضه بخموت المدينه العصيه
على الجنود الروس حتى الان
عاقب قتال عنيف شهيده تلك المنطقه الايام
الماضيه
المكان هذا يكتسبوا اهميه كبيره بالنسبه
للروز اقلها معنويا
قد يجدد تاكيد علو كعب الجلود عسكريا مع
بسط سيطره على مناطق واسعه اما اوكرانيا
فتسعى بكل قوتها للحفاظ على المدينه
وحمايتها فيما اعلن قاده الجيش فيها فشل
القوه الروسيه مشينا الى ان المقاومه
القويه اجبرت روسيا على تحويل اتجاه ناحيه
مناطق اخرى محيطه احتضنت المدينه قبل
الحرب نحو 70,000 شخص بعد مرور 10 اشهر
على الحرب المستعره لم يبقى فيها سوى ثم
سكان اذن الجيش الروسي ومجموعه هجوما واسع
طاقه تمثل المدينه الاوكرانيا حسما دفاعيا
في منطقه الدونتس ولروسيا تشكل بوابه
استراتيجيه لسيطره على كامل دومباز
احيانا يستغرق تطير المنزل اسابيع كامله
اليس كذلك
وروسيا تبقى محمود محطه مهمه تدخل معها
الحرب نفقا جديده
معلق بين فوهات هذه المدافع
عصام عبد السلام العربيه